vuelven los tambores y las carrozas a
las calles de río
el curso de la samba late una vez más en
el carnaval de esa ciudad brasileña
a pesar de no contar como una de las
ediciones más concurridas la de 2022
pasará a la historia como un símbolo de
reapertura para los cariocas
lo más importante es poder ver las caras
la sonrisa las expresiones de las
personas
la sensación que tengo es que este
carnaval marca el regreso a la
normalidad
pero la celebración no solo se lleva a
cabo en las calles en las noches un
estadio dedicado especialmente para la
ocasión se lleva todo el protagonismo el
sambódromo nacido de los diseños del
afamado arquitecto oscar niemeyer se
convierte en la pasarela de las carrozas
que representan a las principales
escuelas de samba del país
en el desfile los vestuarios las
coreografías los temas interpretados y
los diseños de los carruajes temáticos
representan el trabajo de todo un equipo
que lucha por un lugar en las páginas de
la historia cultural de la nación y el
ser coronado como el mejor del país
aunque el retorno sigue marcando la
experiencia de este año
han sido 22 años desfilando desde que
tenía 10 años con la escuela imperatriz
leopoldinense
hay mucha historia fue muy emotivo no
desfilar y ahora ver a todos vivos sanos
es muy emocionante volver a desfilar
todos estamos bien gracias a dios
el carnaval de río comenzó oficialmente
el pasado jueves después de verse
pospuesto por una nueva ola de contagios
causados por la variante omicron por eso
no pocos en las calles de río lo
comparaban con el carnaval de
1919 después de la epidemia de la gripe
española